I'm too tired to know due to Felix to do
I'm from Cape roses and I think I am an
artist I'm not sure to be an artist and
craftsman but what I do is tell her to
define to be within each other when I
with me living ha hey into something
that it was a gift
I started out with a plan that I would
do eight phases they got out of control
I'm doing use of these little figures to
make your faces and I kind of ran out of
when I think it's my time I mean it's
like it big this has been with me to
wrong so I kinda throw away their plans
and the Podesta it's not bad could be
the worst I almost ripped it up like 10
times you almost ripped it up yeah I
used to just tear everything up whenever
I could whenever I got frustrated
especially when I was time I really
school of whale carving my wife didn't
like that so that I I got greedy when I
saw how much the cop was making with my
work and i was making like a heartbeat
dick I got greedy and i discovered i
decided to do something else and this
came along well I was doing making
jewelry yeah I will when I was a
learning how to design dude just could
have gotten away hey and I kind of stuck
to it blood stuff
I'm stuck here all over again you're
stuck to the dry yes like I was with I
wish I could be out there like hunting
him all that travel the world laughter
sit down here just do what I do it's
expected of me hey yeah yeah cuz I I
could really do anything else I work for
the noodle code of justice but I
couldn't really fit in their houses I
just didn't register for a while then
they got bored pretty did this up crazy
what
and Judah in the south I've been to a
lot of art conferences lately and they
talk about the new face of annuit are at
the new face of northern art and they
always show your work point um your work
like new H Christ that you did and I'm
just wondering what you think about that
that you're sort of being held up is
like this iconoclast this edgy edgy
artists hmm don't really like once i
finish this like once you turn my hands
and I don't worry about it anymore
sometimes I when i was carly i would
tell that guy on you you being that
shelf for like 20 years they were
doctors to the rock back but but now i
can't do that was paper this men of some
man meat this was to be able to talk to
talk but one day i'll start carving
again i think
and what kind of stuff did you like to
carve please this is little bit of ass
abstract stuff when i started doing like
body parts sticking out of the most
uptake maybe they start telling me that
allows you do that anymore so I just
cooked and jete I'm curious we've been
talking to a lot of sort of young
artists and whatnot and a lot of them
feel pressured to do kind of traditional
Inuit imagery like do a walrus do a
dancing bear but a year work you've
always gone totally against the grain
why do you think you're so different I
ran to a woman when I was in the Arctic
college and what what just said kind of
stuck to my hair like she was saying
that uh try to keep you work different
everybody else you might find your niche
and I think I didn't I I've never really
felt the pressure any kind of pressure
from anybody to do what I do like I've
always been free to express how I felt
at the moment but sometimes my work
there's some people think they're and
really against something when it like
the New Age Christ like I was picking up
the the Christian churches now Catholics
and Protestants
like how they gone out of the way like
when I read the Bible right sometimes
they look like they're doing something
that they're not allowed to do that that
that the dist camp my head came became
paper maybe that's a misunderstanding
about I think yeah I think so it's just
lots of times I just something I've
observed in the community who are in the
world and I just put it on whatever
working on but it's not something that
comes that but I'm really concerned
about it just something that I am sir I
just guess that's it yeah no big mystery
and the stuff that you observe in the
community what sort of things tend the
day they go against my beliefs and if I
don't like it and I'll tell somebody
I'll go on the radio and put it on paper
I'd just I guess just put it out there
just so that it's showing I'm not hidden
what's an example the new H Christ and
hundreds of thousands or thousands of
carvings have done with the titles at
that moment I would give it that title
but lots of times I would forget what i
was thinking at that time but I always
remember the piece I worked on
brings back what I was thinking at that
time and sometimes I think I messed up
there I was wrong hey when I really like
Rita think about what I have done
sometimes it's too late could go back
and change it so I just have to accept
what I've done even though it was at the
moment at the time and when you do you
or do you think about you do it for
yourself or do you think about what will
sell sometimes I do what I think would
sell but most of the time I just go and
just do wear whatever I please because I
want to do it because I like doing it
most of the time okay some bad things
like a person okay I wanna be doing this
online people they're doing stuff that
different just observe
I can't be a politician man nobody would
vote for me hey even though I know I
could make some positive changes but
maybe with your 20 it people talk about
how it makes them think differently
about the North they talk about how it
makes them feel so you mean a way it's
charger I don't I don't I never really
think of that like I said I'm doing this
like uh I'm not really trying to pull
out a message I'm just making a living
I'm just conveying what absurd
like I'm not trying to change the world
just something that we were allowed to
do in chaos how is the create stuff and
we want to do even though some of the
cars are like stuck with doing polar
bears or inaction well I try not to do
that and sometimes I stuffer ha horrid
just right now at this moment all of the
court will buy my stuff this is
something all people don't see although
maybe sometimes he'll never be able to
go out there sellouts make some money
for a change in pace look I rest of my
main problem I can't wait like the cop
for somebody to come
I'm living day by day doing one walk
west street glad she had poor Billy get
to brunton up my tongue sometimes ha
he's good guy and judo you said you you
like to hunt well what sort of things do
you hunt around here cape dorset kaboom
I can't I can't release you a seal
there's a bit of looking eyes I hate
them too but when I'm hunting
bad bad Lisa don't like the
slaughterhouse help out there I'll be in
one of those in holy smokes the die
screaming today we've been talking to a
lot of hunters on this trip we wear a
Clyde River in iqaluit and a lot of them
are saying that they're starting to
notice the effects of like climate
change and global warming have you
noticed that here in Cape Dorset is a
hunter I'm not really a hunter but I bet
I kind of I guess I until I was nine I
was up there with my parents and I've
never really understood why people are
so concerned about global warning all of
the sudden right before they did didn't
preserve these things like I even
remember her for a couple of years we
are too much snow and nobody made a big
possible Bigfoot we use cover all houses
I guess whether tell somebody please and
there's nothing we can do about it and
according to some books this hasn't
always been like this there used to be
trees here I've heard on TV hey so
climate changes are in New constantly
changing thousands millions of you a lot
of words make your way into your art as
well why do you think that is we'll see
lesson is sometimes I I can't put it to
the car in our fill p
shy of would that put words in there I'm
not doing it for the everybody else but
me hey and can you tell us a little bit
about how you started to make art my
father was cover I just carried on what
he did and the drawings are lipid rafts
this just this just happened like I
watched four years in jerz what the
people are doing one day I do this I was
able to do it nobody complained so I
kept at it hey did I yes like do you
ever think about after the co-op's
bought your work and that's after it
gets down south and it makes its way
into collections like do you ever think
about who buys your art what they do
with it how they present it not not
really it's just something I do because
I have to make a living here now but we
would I don't really worry about what
goes on out there that somebody else are
you doing that out there means down
south anywhere and Judea was curious you
know when there's these art conferences
at the universities or the museum's
their theme is always Inuit art and I'm
wondering for you do you see yourself as
an Inuit artist yourself as a Canadian
artist that lives and works in the north
like how do you define yourself and what
you do don't this is just something that
matters
good
because I'm not doing this for a second
I used to do it with the sake of her but
it became something else why did it
became something that uh I have to make
a living with this make my kids and
please my wife
but do you think the kind of work you do
should it be in galleries that
specialize in modern art and abstract
art or should it be in galleries that
specialize and quote unquote Inuit art
that I don't want to worry about that as
a matter of fact I I don't like
galleries hey there the greediest but
two people in this planet I don't know
why they will chair there well well with
us I mean we're the ones coming up is
this the territorial but I've never
understood why I waited we don't get to
financial in did i do you feel like the
art world misunderstands you and your
work ah I don't really care about that
world all right whatever be within
c'mere I don't I don't care I don't know
why I think I'm to isolate it hey what
you wrong hey I'm just like hey sit down
just like Italy I share with you this
because we have to
this matter of fact I prefer this over
top in the day I don't know very good
people skills
I I plans for this but they all failed I
was going to do the air of these two
minute little Terry would take forever
napkin worth isn't mean wow I have to
eat if i take too long this it becomes
like worthless not was my time even
though atari kind worthless now i swears
i'm concerned but the couple of this
stuff because Felix puts bread nip
tables what times have a good after that
you
and is this piece almost finished or we
still have a lot of work to do it's
almost done big I think well I never
really had never really finished it's
done more than stretched sometimes you
say worked on it tomorrow like this I
can work on a drawing for years and
years and everything I suppose that
that's how people and what people end up
doing I won't be I kind of saw that when
I was making jewelry did I wouldn't ear
works is actually chosen for the cape
dorset print collection how do you feel
I just started this like last year I
think I haven't really had a chance to
but nu H Christ for example that was in
the 2008 collect yes duh that one kind
of got away like I thought I was
thinking of trying to stop it plan I've
started I've stopped a couple of
Edison's here I don't like the way they
would hold everything
do you think the cape dorset print
collection is going to survive over the
next 50 years we had the 50th
anniversary last year is it going to
survive for another 50 years I hope so
how has been going like down according
to the guests the world world market
isn't but then we crash ocular crisis
the town died when the world market
crashed even the what's happening now
its effectiveness you mean less people
are buying her Victor the worse and
stuff there then i buy as much so we we
stuck I suppose we asked for this when
we could maneuver we're under an
umbrella for years and years safe from
outside world ha and we had no idea what
most of us don't still with us you knew
in new people brothers it's always been
us and then her vanities first then
anybody out there you the rest here
curious boats do your kids one of the
artists like you I don't want them to to
be a hard life I'd rather have been
working when coming my nose
what would you do if one of your kids
said they absolutely did want to be an
artist okay I do it would be something
least is Tolton
you